¿De qué se mueren los hombres?
La primera causa de muerte
en los varones
son las enfermedades cardiovasculares.
Y las mujeres sabemos esto,
porque, a lo largo de la vida,
cuidamos a nuestros hombres.
También sabemos
por qué pueden enfermarse.
Hace unos años ya,
desde un programa que hacemos
en la Fundación Cardiológica Argentina,
hicimos una encuesta
en una muestra representativa
del área metropolitana de Buenos Aires
de 600 mujeres
y les hicimos preguntas
sobre factores de riesgo.
80 % de las mujeres sabía que condiciones
como tener presión arterial alta
colesterol elevado,
ser diabético o fumar
son factores que aumentan
el riesgo cardiovascular.
El 90 % de las encuestadas
sabía que el dolor de pecho
puede ser un síntoma
de infarto cardíaco.
Y la gran mayoría,
además, tenía información
acerca de todas las conductas
que previenen o ayudan a controlar
la enfermedad cardiovascular.
A esas mismas mujeres
les preguntamos:
"¿Cuál es la primera causa de muerte
en las mujeres?".
Y, como pueden ver, más de la mitad
contestó que el cáncer, en general.
Y muchas que el cáncer de mama,
en particular.
Pero ¿de qué se mueren
en realidad las mujeres?
En Argentina, 1 de cada 3 mujeres muere
por enfermedades cardiovasculares.
Muchas más muertes que si sumamos
las que ocurren por todos los tipos
de cáncer, por SIDA y por accidentes.
Estos son datos del Ministerio
de Salud de la Nación
y, como ven, desde el año 2007,
en nuestro país,
mueren incluso más mujeres
que hombres por causa cardiovascular.
Hoy, 135.
Y una en los próximos 11 minutos.
Yo soy médica cardióloga
y desde el año 2006 tengo el compromiso
de combatir dos realidades:
la primera es esta: sin duda,
la enfermedad cardiovascular
representa el principal problema
de salud que tienen las mujeres;
y la segunda es que, como les mostré,
la mayoría de las mujeres
desconoce ese dato y tiene una percepción
que difiere de la realidad.
Los factores de riesgo cardiovascular
¿son los mismos?
Yo digo "diabetes, hipertensión,
sedentarismo, estrés, sobrepeso".
Al mencionarlos, pareciera que sí,
pero esto no necesariamente es así.
Si hablamos de sobrepeso, no es lo mismo
en hombres que en mujeres.
En la mayoría de los hombres la grasa
se concentra en la panza,
mientras que en la mayoría de las mujeres
la grasa se concentra en las caderas.
Y, para el corazón,
pareciera ser más nociva
la distribución abdominal de la grasa.
Por otro lado, el impacto
que tienen los factores de riesgo
también es distinto por género.
La diabetes, por ponerles un ejemplo.
Ser diabético es un factor de riesgo
para los hombres y para las mujeres.
Si un hombre es diabético,
tiene 2.6 veces más riesgo
de tener un infarto
que si un hombre no es diabético.
Pero si una mujer tiene diabetes,
tiene más de 4 veces de chances
de tener un infarto que una mujer
que no tiene diabetes.
Igual ocurre con la hipertensión arterial
o con el sedentarismo,
que aumentan la chance de un infarto,
mucho más en las mujeres
que en los varones.
Y, por el contrario, el tabaquismo tiene
un ligero peor impacto
en los hombres que en las mujeres.
Y el tercer punto,
en relación a los factores de riesgo,
es que es posible que existan condiciones
que son propias de las mujeres,
y que aumenten el riesgo de enfermarse,
y que no conocemos.
Y esto tiene que ver
con que, históricamente,
las enfermedades cardiovasculares
han sido estudiadas en los varones.
Y extrapolar la evidencia
que proviene de los hombres a las mujeres
puede ser un error.
Así como estudiar a las mujeres
puede traer sorpresas.
Déjenme darles un ejemplo:
tal vez muchos hayan escuchado
que las mujeres, en edad fértil,
tienen menos riesgo de enfermarse,
por efecto de las hormonas sexuales.
Una protección que se pierde
a partir de la menopausia.
Bueno, durante muchos años,
muchas mujeres
fueron tratadas con terapia
de reemplazo hormonal.
Se las reemplazaba con parches
con hormonas similares a aquellas
que ya habían dejado de tener.
Bueno, solo los estudios de investigación
que incluyeron a miles de mujeres
seguidas durante muchos años
pudieron poner de manifiesto
que el reemplazo hormonal,
lejos de proteger al corazón,
aumentaba el riesgo cardiovascular.
A las mujeres nos mata
que nos reemplacen
y esto es la evidencia científica.
Pero, además de eso,
es un buen ejemplo de que las mujeres
tienen que ser todavía,
objeto de estudio.
La medicina hoy, fundamentalmente,
está basada en estos estudios clínicos.
Y aún en la actualidad, las mujeres
siguen estando subrepresentadas
en los estudios de investigación.
Y esto es una cosa que podemos cambiar.
Puedo mostrarles datos
de insuficiencia cardíaca,
pero podría mostrarles de cualquiera
de las enfermedades cardiovasculares.
La proporción de mujeres incluidas
en estudios de investigación,
en ese caso con drogas para tratamiento
de insuficiencia cardíaca,
es menor al 30 %.
Cuando en realidad,
si uno agarra toda la población
que tiene insuficiencia cardíaca,
más de la mitad son mujeres.
Al principio de la charla,
les hablé de los síntomas.
Y quiero detenerme en esto:
si también existen diferencias
en los síntomas
entre los hombres y las mujeres.
Voy a hablar de infarto cardíaco.
El síntoma típico de un infarto
es el dolor de pecho, opresivo,
descrito hace más de 200 años
por un hombre,
en base a lo observado en hombres,
y en ese entonces leído por hombres.
Pero existen otros síntomas,
que se llaman atípicos,
en contraposición a lo típico,
y que son el dolor de espalda,
las náuseas, la fatiga,
la sensación de indigestión.
Y, a priori, uno pensaría que atípico
suena a "raro" o "infrecuente".
Bueno, casi la mitad de las mujeres
que tienen un infarto
tienen síntomas atípicos.
Y es posible que si la descripción
del infarto hubiera sido hecha
en base a hombres y a mujeres,
a esto que llamamos atípico
lo hubiéramos denominado de otra manera.
"Femenino".
Lo cierto es que la dificultad que supone
a veces esta atipicidad de los síntomas
tiene consecuencias
que son muy importantes.
Y ocurre aún, cuando las mujeres
tienen presentaciones típicas,
que es difícil hacer un diagnóstico
por lo siguiente.
Un hombre entra a una guardia
con un infarto,
o la mayoría de ellos,
diciendo esto:
"Tengo un dolor de pecho que me aprieta,
como si tuviera
la pata de un elefante parado encima".
Y todos corremos.
Esto es lo habitual.
Pero muchas mujeres
hacen un relato del dolor que es distinto.
Algo más asociado
a los sentimientos, algo como:
"Tengo una sensación como de angustia,
como si necesitara suspirar".
Y nadie corre.
Porque es un relato más complejo.
Y, ante un infarto,
es muy importante ser claros.
Porque lo que ocurre
es que se tapa una arteria,
se obstruye bruscamente el flujo
que pasa por esa arteria,
y deja de irrigarse el músculo cardíaco.
Y por cada minuto de demora
hasta que se abre esa arteria,
mayor es el daño del corazón,
y, obviamente,
mayor es la probabilidad de morirse.
Cada minuto cuenta.
Algo que es de sentido común,
pero que además,
ha sido demostrado científicamente
es que de quienes tienen un infarto
los que antes llegan al hospital son
los que, cuando empezaron a sentirse mal,
se dieron cuenta de que efectivamente
estaban teniendo un ataque cardíaco.
Y el darse cuenta, el estar
en presencia de un cuadro clínico,
se construye mentalmente.
Por un lado; con el reconocimiento
de los síntomas
y, por otro lado, si uno cree
que lo que está ocurriendo es posible.
Y esto último es viable solo si uno sabe
que puede enfermarse.
Déjenme contarles
el caso de Loli.
Loli es una paciente
a la que conocí hace unos años
cuando entró al hospital
con un infarto.
Loli empezó a sentirse mal
estando en un taxi,
muy cerca del hospital.
Y le dijo al taxista
que la lleve a la casa,
"para no preocupar a mi marido".
porque tenía exámenes que corregir.
Ella es profesora.
Porque, como muchas mujeres,
sentía que tenía
algunas responsabilidades familiares
que no podía delegar.
Porque creyó que se le iba a pasar.
Y porque, en definitiva, nunca se imaginó
que lo que estaba teniendo
era un infarto.
El caso de Loli no es una excepción.
En Argentina, un estudio
que se hizo demostró
que las mujeres consultan, en promedio,
casi 2 horas más tarde que los hombres.
Y esto significa
menos probabilidad de vivir.
Otro caso.
Ana María, una mujer
que estaba en su auto,
en un semáforo, parada.
Viene de atrás un camión
que lleva congelados,
que no frenó y la chocó de atrás.
Entonces ella se baja,
algo aturdida, del auto,
sin lesiones graves.
Cuando ve cómo está su auto,
empieza a discutir con el camionero
y en el medio de la discusión
empieza a tener dolor de pecho.
Al poco tiempo, llega la ambulancia,
le ponen un collar de Filadelfia,
la llevan al hospital. Entra diciendo
que le dolía el pecho,
y la llevan a hacerse una serie
de radiografías y tomografías,
para descartar
lesiones asociadas al accidente.
Esto es meramente especulativo,
pero es posible que si Ana Maria
hubiera sido un hombre que entraba
a la guardia de un hospital,
tras un estrés hiperagudo
como el que supone tener un accidente
diciendo que le dolía el pecho,
lo primero que hubieran hecho los médicos
es un electrocardiograma,
para descartar que no tenía un infarto,
antes de llevarla a la sala de rayos.
Entonces, las demoras
de las mismas pacientes a consultar,
las demoras que a veces
tiene el sistema de salud
y la dificultad diagnóstica
que a veces supone
esta "atipicidad" de los síntomas,
determina que acá, en Argentina,
pero también en el resto del mundo,
las mujeres reciban menos tratamiento
para el infarto.
Y una consecuencia evitable es
que el hecho de que reciban
menos tratamiento de algún modo
explica, entre otras cosas,
que una mujer con un infarto
se muera más
que un hombre con infarto.
Creo que es muy importante
que desde la comunidad médico-científica
incrementemos
la investigación clínica en mujeres.
Que luego, desde lo asistencial,
efectivamente les brindemos,
les aseguremos que van a tener
el mejor tratamiento disponible.
Y el resto tiene que ver con la comunidad,
con que podamos generar conciencia.
Si ustedes que son mujeres
y también ustedes que son varones,
se convencen de que las mujeres
pueden enfermarse del corazón,
entonces esto puede tener
dos consecuencias muy importantes.
La primera tiene
que ver con la prevención:
que las mujeres
adopten conductas saludables,
que consulten
periódicamente al médico,
que conozcan cuál es su riesgo vascular,
que los varones empiecen
a cuidar al corazón de las mujeres,
del mismo modo en que las mujeres cuidamos
el corazón de nuestros hombres.
Y la segunda consecuencia
es que, ante la eventualidad
de que una mujer tenga algo,
que rápidamente consulte.
Porque eso
puede salvarle la vida.
Hace unos meses,
estábamos reunidos
en una sobremesa con amigos,
yo en ese momento estaba trabajando
en una campaña de concientización
y estaba muy entusiasmada
con esta idea de que una simple campaña
puede salvarle la vida a alguien.
Y alguien me dijo:
"Vos no podés esperar
que los demás sueñen tu sueño".
Y yo espero, profundamente,
que el que me lo dijo esté equivocado.
Así que les pido a todos,
por favor, que nos ayuden
y se comprometan a contar esto.
Y es que: "El corazón de una mujer
puede romperse EN SERIO".
(Aplausos)